[Music]  5 25 on your Monday morning and when you  talk about going around in circles about  roundabouts  the city of Las Vegas has put in three  traffic circles on a short stretch of  Cimarron between Sahara and Okie  are the ones at El parque  and O'Bannon seem to be doing fine  although there have been no changes to  widen the intersections to accommodate  the not so easy to see short curved  circles and that may have been what led  to this at the third circle at Via  oliveiro just north of Sahara  so all I can figure is that somebody or  several somebody's were complaining  about Speeders on Cimarron that's  halfway between Buffalo and Durango  comments about the circles on the city  of Las Vegas Facebook posts haven't been  too kind what do you think buckle up  drive carefully please put down their  phone and you can join the driving you  crazy conversation the email address  traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com